the last Jedi has been dividing fans
since its release some fans think it's
the best installment since the Empire
Strikes Back while others call it the
worst thing to happen to star wars since
Jar Jar Binks one thing's for sure it'll
be a long time before anyone can agree
on it but there must be balance in the
force so let's take a look at both the
worst and best moments from the last
Jedi let's start with the best and work
our way to the dark side of the last
Jedi spoilers ahead whole dough's
sacrifice although the various mishaps
leading up to this dramatic scene leave
much to be desired vice-admiral Hodos
heroic decision to take the resistance
flagship on a kamikaze hyperspace jump
directly in the sope ship was one of the
most shocking parts of the last Jedi the
amazing visual effects of this collision
made for a particularly impactful moment
and there's no question that whole dose
selfless and inspiring maneuver will go
down as one of the most incredible Star
Wars moments of all time kylo and Rey's
fight the battle between rey kylo and
supreme leader snoke praetorian guard
was one of the definite highlights of
the last Jedi sure many Star Wars fans
probably wanted a traditional lightsaber
clash between kylo and Rey but between
the exceptional fight choreography and
the thrill of seeing the to come
together to defeat snoke's bodyguards
this unique battle was a standout moment
for the movie and the franchise escape
from canto bites while many a thin and
roses scenes were appointed division
among audiences the duo's escape from
the casino at Kanto bite was probably
the most rewarding part of their time
together
aided by slave children the pair climb
aboard one of the space horses and ride
it to freedom smashing through the
casino and streets in the process after
being pinned down by the local police on
the cliffside rose removes the saddle
from her father and sets it free
she and Fenton share a moment reveling
in the damage they did to the wealthy
resort city Yoda trolls Luke Star Wars
fans hungry for some original trilogy
nostalgia were probably pleased by the
fact that practical puppetry effects
were used for Yoda's force ghost
appearance and Frank Oz also returned to
voice the character also returning to
the last Jedi was Yoda's trademark
quirky sense of humor a Yoda quite
unlike the serious Jedi Mass
you're seen in the prequel movies Yoda
surprises both Luke and the audience by
calling down lightning to strike the
tree containing the Jedi Order texts we
later learned that Rey stole the ancient
Jedi texts and hid them aboard the
Millennium Falcon but Luke doesn't know
that Yoda is just doing what he did back
on Dagobah teasing Luke for the fun of
it
Luke trolls kylo Luke's final scenes in
the last Jedi were among the best in the
entire film after mysteriously appearing
on crates Luke has a short visit with
his sister Leia before walking out alone
on the salt plane to confront his nephew
Luke toys with kylo giving Leia and the
others time to escape after promising to
haunt kylo and telling him that he will
not be the last Jedi the truth is
revealed Luke has been using the force
to project an image of himself across
the galaxy back on his secluded Island
Luke passes away peacefully from the
massive effort presumably becoming one
with the force and while these scenes
represent the best of the last Jedi
there are plenty of moments that may
have made the audience cringe Skye
walking one of the most surprising
moments of the last Jedi was when Leia
uses the force to pull herself back
through space to the damaged resistance
flagship we've never seen Leia use the
force like that at least not in a movie
it's long been known that she has the
same potential power as her twin brother
Luke
so the concept itself didn't come out of
the blue what really made this one of
the worst moments of the last Jedi was
the way it was executed with Leia
looking kind of like a sci-fi Mary
Poppins as she flies back through the
shattered bridge of the Rattus it came
across a little silly and we already had
one incredible Mary Poppins scene this
year any out hoes mutiny after Leia is
incapacitated during the attack on the
Radice Poe seems surprised when
vice-admiral whole dough steps in to
command the resistance they soon butt
heads when whole dough refuses to tell
Poe winter planners so Poe impulsively
sends Finn and Rose on a risky mission
with very little chance of success but
that's not enough later Poe becomes
convinced whole dough is preparing to
abandon ship
and he initiates a mutiny against her
while failure was a major theme of the
last Jedi it was extremely painful to
watch Poe fail so badly and get so many
people blown up in the process the
casino rose and Finn's escaped from the
casino on canto bite was entertaining
but the time spent at the gambling den
hunting for a master code breaker was
another matter entirely first Rose and
Finn where their scruffy resistance
uniforms in the high-class joint and go
mostly undetected until a simple parking
violation gets them caught that's
unbelievable enough then they
coincidentally happen to meet a
different Code Breaker in their jail
cell who just happens to have the same
set of skills as the person they were
trying to find while code breaker number
2 DJ ended up being an interesting
character who offers some important
elements to the plot audiences couldn't
help but wonder why he wasn't the main
focus of the mission to begin with
instead of relying on such an
implausible coincidence to get him
involved snoke's exit one of the most
controversial moments from the last Jedi
is the demise of Supreme Leader Snoke
at the hands of kylo Ren the scene
itself was played out pretty well but
some audiences definitely felt let down
by the Supreme Leader's anticlimactic
end after Snoke was introduced in the
force awakens fans feverishly speculated
about snoke's backstory and identity
only to be disappointed when he kicked
the bucket so abruptly it didn't
particularly help that Andy Serkis who
plays Snoke fed the speculation by
revealing tidbits about snoke's tortured
past and implying he'd have a much
larger role to play in the future
roses heroics one of the biggest
strengths of the last Jedi was his
character development Finn began the
film terrified of the first order and
ready to run
and his only motivations are protecting
himself in red meeting rose and joining
her for their abortive quest teaches
finn a lot about himself and what it
means to stand up for what's right by
the time the resistance makes its last
stand on crate finn is a completely
changed man one totally ready to give
his life for the cause by going
independence day on the first order
then rose saves fan at the last moment
putting a quick stop to that Redemption
arc but there were no consequences
Rose survives and Finn somehow gets her
back across the active battlefield
safely this spike crashing right in
front of the whole first-order army and
their millions of lasers leaving many
viewers asking rose will you stop being
an idiot thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel let's check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to